reg were hot on this topic here of and
everybody in America is talking about
this is Ben Simmons a rookie
you're asking me personally yes no he's
no no not a rookie so you shouldn't be
Ella not a rookie in here I've never
been a fan of that I know the lead does
if you don't play your rookie year and
you're out for some unforeseen injury
when you come back you're slated to be a
rookie you're working with NBA trainers
in VA coaches you're getting and I know
they're like he never played an NBA game
but you're around the NBA lifestyle
you're traveling with the team even
though you're not participating you're
around that environment you're in NBA
weight rooms you're watching the NBA
film so personally no but I still think
he will win the Rookie of the Year in my
opinion I'm gonna be voting for Donovan
Mitchell for Rookie of the Year but he
is not it's like you're a red shirt
freshman a red shirt freshman is a
little bit more ahead of the game than a
regular freshman coming in because he's
been around that system here's a stat
for you five rookies have led their team
in scoring and their team's won at least
45 games in NBA history I bet you I
could name them okay Larry Bird yes
David Robinson yes
maybe Wilt Chamberlain yes I would put
Michael Jordan in there Michael Jordan
no I don't think they were very good
though when they got there when he got
there oh yes they weren't they were
Danny Warren Orlando three of the five
the UH elendor war yeah when Orlando the
other two Orlando Kareem abdul-jabbar
when he was with the Fox team that's
right and and and Oh Matthew Johnson no
no no Donovan Mitchell was a pad for
good mental juror okay yeah all right
that's pretty yes and you're right
Orlando Woolridge
Reggie Theus that was not scaring anyone
backward Michael Jordan was a rookie
Reggie Theus was I remember Reggie was
didn't Jordan and Reggie Theus have like
a thing like they Mike always tried to
go after Reggie Theus do you remember
that uh I don't know I do not know but
Reggie Sears was a bad boy back in this
day especially as you know Vijay's it
was oh yeah Reggie was like that yeah he
was a lot of fun what's the first round
matchup that you want to see if the
scenes stay as they are is that what
you're saying yes this is it because
there's a like a hundred plus scenarios
where things can change
well obviously Golden State in OKC right
wouldn't it be a fun matchup to see
Kevin Durant go against his former team
and you know maybe a light turns on for
the Thunder and they figure out a way to
you know play as a unit and I think that
would be a fun matchup I really want to
see why people are going to say I'm a
homework Cleveland in Indiana Indiana
has had Cleveland number this year
Victor Oladipo
really has put the Pacers on their back
I think they are playing if as good as
anyone in the Eastern Conference and
look I I don't think the Pacers can beat
Cleveland but I sure think it would be
an interesting matchup
especially what happened the last couple
of years I mean Paul George had a couple
of those shots there were close games in
the first two games last year versus the
Cavs yeah I think that'd be a fun
matchup to watch how close will the MVP
race be I think it'll be closer than
what people think
I still believe James Harden will win
um probably on the side of leaning
towards voting for LeBron James because
you know we had in our production
meeting we I told the guys let's just
play the what if game
what if LeBron James was on Houston with
the team with Chris Paul and what if
James Harden was on the Cleveland team
Kevin Love
Clarkson Nance I still think the Houston
team would be 64 65 wins but would
because leaving team be where they are
before earth the third or fourth fourth
slot I believe right now I'm not sure
don't get me wrong James Harden would
still have his numbers but with the team
be as good
what if okay so I am plus I'm a little
old-school Michael Jordan should have
won the MVP every single year I know
Charles wanted one year and then what
happened
got embarrassed by George in the final
Karl Malone want it twice Walt through
Jordan and what did MJ do beat him twice
yeah not that LeBron is gonna beat
anyone out west because I don't believe
cleaving can beat Houston or Golden
State if they got to the finals but
LeBron James is the best player Michael
Jordan was the best player but didn't
win it every year and you got a reward
James Harden and that's why I think he
will win it because of the team's
success 65 wins may be 66 tonight and
body of work what I mean he's been
runner-up the last two years yeah that's
why he will win it I'd gave you my
reasons on why I'm probably leaning
towards LeBron I think LeBrons been more
valuable but we go with the best player
on the best team or the best record on
the best team yeah and I and I hold it I
hold the Bron accountable for what
happens with the front oh you know the
moves that they make because he's
involved in it whether he admits it or
not yeah and and you know to bring
people in and then it just didn't go
well this second wave this younger group
that came in you know it's not his fault
that Kevin Love got hurt or Tristan
Thompson you know hasn't played well at
all but you know Isiah Thomas never felt
comfortable there you make these moves
and it feels like LeBrons I have to hold
him accountable for that and that's
probably why I wouldn't have him win it
but I think he's been more valuable than
Harden this would be a no-brainer
situation if James Harden went down
December 31st and that's when Cleveland
really imploded that month of January if
they didn't employ
and LeBron played like LeBron that you
know we've seen the last month and a
half two months I would have gone with
LeBron because he had an opportunity
when James Harden was down James Harden
came back and then remember that sixty
point triple-double and his team took
off 17 or 18 game win streak and the
rest is history
so I agree with you hundred percent
because LeBron is you've got to hold him
accountable for the implosion that the
cast went through through that month of
January they somewhat righted the ship
but it needed to be done when they
brought in the young players and
Clarkson Larry Nance Jr but as much as
we're gonna praise LeBron and which I do
you've got to also hold him accountable
because that was on his watch what
happened to the Cavs the month of
January russell westbrook has a chance
to average a triple-double for the
second straight season how important do
you think it is to him he needs 16
rebounds tonight against Memphis I bet
you get 17 III don't know how important
it is to him but in terms of a historic
stance I mean we've never seen that and
[Music]
quietly as his cabinet has any kind of
crept into the MVP conversation him yes
[Music]
last year you know you know we just
talked about you know you got to give
the MVP to the player on the best team
and all that well
OKC didn't have the best year last year
but no one was expecting with the
departure of Durant that the Thunder
we're gonna win 47 games and Westbrook
was gonna average a triple-double that's
why I leaned heavily towards Westbrook
over harden last year winning the MVP
but to do it in back-to-back years even
though this Thunder has not played up to
expectations right now who is your top
I'll tell you who my top five because I
do have a vote this year who would be my
top five my lord Harden wait you just
said you would pick LeBron
right LeBron hard I'm going in order hi
okay so I said LeBron and then you were
agreeing okay so LeBron hard Martin I
went with a de Anthony doing something I
went with a little 'red Damian Lillard
thing and I went with Durant fourth but
I'm gonna say this because I have not
turned in my sheet yet if he gets 17
rebounds tonight and averages a
double-double I might put Russell
Westbrook v over KT mmm here's my
there's a bigger question so the
over-under rebounds for Russell
Westbrook jr. the third tonight is 16
over/under points scored by Memphis
tonight against Oklahoma City I did it
at 78 you're saying they will score
under 78 yeah I'm thinkin maybe so bad I
know they're bad I know when they're
good at bad like they're good at being
bad yes they are
I'm glad you didn't use a capital T word
because I don't think they're taking
they're just bad wait you don't know if
this is tanking wait you think this is
an Alexander this bad wait are you told
by the Commissioner you're not abused
word tanking is that what's going on
here do you think the Commissioner
sister anyone on Turner they my sister
that other network anyone on Terra could
you start for Memphis now we had this
conversation five years ago during the
playoffs first in San Antonio you could
start for Memphis
Theodore yes we all could start for
Memphis well we all could hey before I
let you know this Andre Ingram story was
pretty cool so he's he's 32 and he
finally got called up he had been 10
years in the Developmental League and
then I loved that the Lakers were saying
dude shoot it every time you get it and
you know he put up some good numbers
last night 6 of 8 from the floor 4 or 5
from three-point range
that's good it's not only not only
shooting every time Luke Walton told us
before the game I'm running every time
he's on the floor I'm running every
single play for him because his dude
Serie A and for him to fly his family in
his his wife and two daughters from
Virginia I mean to get the call and to
walk into the room because he was
thinking oh god this X's meaning is kind
of awkward because as soon as he walked
in there was Magic Johnson and Bob
Pollin he's like oh my god I probably
didn't trade her cut or you know another
long bus ride somewhere and they're like
he was just shot you're up here for the
last two games and I'm talking you
talking about a quick trigger microwave
as soon as the ball touch his hand it
was out you're ready to go hello I love
it kudos to him all right so you don't
know where you're going for the first
round of the playoffs man we have zero
idea where we're going but you're doing
West right I have no idea we have zero
idea I don't know we don't know there's
a lot of things like it better in play
from tonight you find out after tonight
before we go let me ask you and the guys
question because there's a big playing
game tonight who do you like Denver at
Minnesota huge game playing whoever wins
is in ok my brother you like one game I
like Denver
I hope they win because they they're
earning it whereas Minnesota it feels
like they just let this slip away and I
don't think they're deserving of it the
weight you know Denver is played and you
know I'd like to see them rewarded do
you think in that Western Conference who
would be a better first-round matchup
for Houston see Denver
and it's eight so they beat Minnesota
they hold the tiebreakers for all those
teams that are above them yeah so they
would leapfrog to six or seven so it's
Minnesota wins they play Houston
if Denver wins I mean it could be I
don't know who's gonna be an eight well
men you know Minnesota's got a lot of
talent and some star power there but you
know that's the problem like they're
holding on for dear life just to make it
into the playoffs so right that's the
surprising element there all right well
good luck finding out where you're going
thank you I appreciate look forward to
talking points with you guys next week
all right he's Reggie Miller he doesn't
use the word tanking Thank You red they
weren't playing up to expectations is
that close the tanking yeah something
like that
okay you're playing up to expectations
thank you thanks guys that's Reggie
Aloysius Miller junior the third brought
to you by 2018 Mercedes AMG e-class a
suite of innovative technologies one of
the most intelligent cars on the road go
to MBUSA comm or visit your local
dealership to schedule your test drive
today for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]